when you talk about memory recall which
is interesting I I can't help but see
parallels between him and Magnus Carlson
who's a chess player who's the number
one in the world
the arguably the best ever certainly the
best ever if you just look at Absolute
numbers the chess has the luxury of
having a rating
uh which you can't have it cannot have
in Jiu Jitsu because it's a game of
human chess chess is just a board game
so you can actually calculate the
probability that you could win so he is
the highest ELO rating uh ever and he's
maintained that rating he can without
competing against
the number two in the world he could
just prove that he's the number one in
the world for many years uh anyway
there's uh certain similarities one's
ability to re recall so memory recall of
information is fascinatingly good and
the other one is not so much a love for
Perfection which is something you
mentioned but yeah the flip side of that
which is what you also mentioned is the
hate of imperfection uh now in the case
of Magnus
it almost uh
creates a level of anxiety for him
that's almost destructive
so the thing he seems to hate the most
is imperfection against people he knows
are worse than him
so the thing he loves is competing
against people that are close to the
skill level or the favorite is people
who are might actually be better than
him especially in certain positions he
loves competing against them he hates
competing against people that are
um still from the perspective of
everyone else
uh what are called super Grand Masters
so top three in the world but he knows
he's much better than them and the
anxiety of being not perfect against
those people that's why that's why he I
don't know if you're paying attention
but he stepped away he's not going to
defend his world championship
uh because he hates the anxiety of
playing people worse than him
interesting he figures they would
somehow make him look bad or no he just
for him at least the language he uses is
just not fun
and he likes having fun it's to him it
was fun to win no matter the skill level
the world championship the first time
but then defending it is a very grueling
process
is
um
with classical chess you play these many
hours could be seven hour long games
and
uh on on top of that he really hates the
fact that it's only I forget what it is
but it's single digit number of games he
says it's it's low sample
so uh I can't
I would like to play 20 30 40 50 games
if we're going to do it this way but
then they're too long it's going to take
too long so he's really emphasizes the
the the fun of it and the clear
demonstration of who's the best now
chess
is an interesting game it's probably
different than grappling because it's
been played for centuries so there's
this giant body of people that are
playing it like there's other Gordon
Ryan's out there imagine a world where
there's multiple Gordon Ryan's or
something like that different dimensions
but uh you have like sharks everywhere
and so there there is fun to be had even
at the very very very very top but the
the memory recall is the thing that
stands out and the hate of imperfection
uh more intense than anybody else in the
game fascinating